do your windows need to be cleaned
do your homeschool lessons on them
it'll force you to clean you're welcome for that cleaning hack
by the way we are doing our homeschool lessons way late today
because the kids spent the night at their grandparents house
and didn't get home till lunch
well I just wouldn't even do lessons today
because my kids are typically in a bad mood when they get home
I'm trying to get out of the habit as kind these days is a loss
because they do spend a lot of time at their grandparents
and that just can't be an excuse to not get our score
so we're gonna get in a quick math and reading practice today
but I'm not gonna teach anything
I kept it super simple
we practice two digit edition with carrying over your regular words
we did some of our word cards and I did a read a lot
if you pay any attention to education and school related news
you know that reading is a hot topic right now
because a lot of public schools are failing
when it comes to teaching our kids how to read
and as a former teacher
I can tell you I was not properly trained to teach children how to read
I spent the last year doing courses and trainings
on how to teach my daughter how to read
because she struggled so much through our kindergarten
I am a firm believer that kids are gonna read on their own timeline
you don't have to be reading at the end of kindergarten
however I do
you know what is so so important to provide good reading instruct
so let this be encouragement
that if your kindergarten or first grader isn't reading fluently
it's okay focus your attention on providing high quality
multi sensory reading instruction
and eventually they will get
in the meantime fill your home with lots of colorful books
read a lot of read alouds
and help them fall in love with learning